well speaking of father's day it's time
to get creative and make 2022 the year
of the father's day gift wins forget the
socks ties and t-shirts why not get the
father figure in your life something
he's eager to use every day we have a
few ideas to help
dads often help fix things and that's
usually a good hint for gifting this
ryobi 18 volt one plus drill it's a
hammer drill it's great for any project
if that has a bunch of tools milwaukee
has a terrific rolling tool chest ryobi
has this 40 volt lithium platform it's
cordless there's a combo kit with a
string trimmer and a blower in a survey
the home depot recently asked dads what
they really want two out of three dads
admitted
that they were hard to shop for
but they also said that they really
wanted something that they could use all
the time more than 70 percent wanted
something they could enjoy with the
family smart technology has come to
grilling so we have a complete lineup
like the next grill nevo 720 propane gas
digital smart grill or the traeger pro
780 wi-fi pellet grill and smoker and
then think about some rest and
relaxation don't overlook you know
spending some nice quality time outside
with dad head to homedepot.com for more
gift ideas